when i fight someone it happened very
often in my career
like when i fight someone you have
a connection with the guy you fight a
lot of things
happen here and real fighter will know
that what i'm talking about the
connection that we have because you look
at each other
and these this connection you cannot see
it when you watch a fight on tv
but very often in most of my fight
when i went to decision i could see that
guy break
breaking folding like he's letting me
know that
he doesn't fight to win anymore he's
fighting to not lose
and like i said earlier it's not up to
me trying to
trying to push that pace trying to to
finish him and
increasing my risk of getting cut by a
counter punch and getting knocked out
you know it's up to him to take the risk
you know because he's losing the fight
and the idea in this game you want to
save yourself for another day i mean
it's
sad to say for the family this is the
this is the truth if you win and
that's what you're doing is good you win
you're winning the fight you know
you you're going to get paid the the
same amount of money of course if you
have like an highlight wheel
something like that it could increase
your pay but but in terms of
your career i believe you should see
your career as a marathon not as a
sprint
so you you kind of save yourself and a
lot of time i fought guys
i could see in their face that oh he
doesn't want to be there anymore like i
know i'm winning the fight before even
the fight is over
they get desperate of course they're
gonna throw a haymaker or something but
i know they're not gonna take any risk
because they
they're they're hurt they lost already
they know that i'm better than them
and that's when i know i get the fight
and i know that i'm just need to be on
cruise control i can win
if they don't like it's hard to to
finish someone
who doesn't fight to win anymore right
you see very often
champions in in mma
have a very dominate dominant career in
the beginning
you know they finish a lot of their
opponent but after a while it become
it kind of peak because oh the entire
ufc roaster is studying you
and they figure you out maybe they
didn't figure you out out to beat you
but they figure
out how to kind of survive and and hang
in there with you
jon jones is a good example that right
everybody myself same thing like every
like a lot of guy anderson silver
the the all the the champions that's
what happened everyone's studying you
yes it